-Welcome back to the show.
Thank you so much for coming.
-Thanks, man.
-Thanks for having me.
-How is the fam?
I was very lucky to meet
your beautiful daughter
backstage.
Frankie.
-Frankie came with me, yeah.
-She's a good kid.
-She's a great kid.
You know, most of the time,
she's a great kid.
She's 14, you know, so, like,
I'm here in New York
because I'm working.
I'm shooting season two
of "Severance."
[ Cheers and applause ]
But my family lives
in Los Angeles
so we spend a ton of time
on Face Time, you know,
like, constantly,
because it's terrible being
on opposite sides
of the country -- it's hard.
So we're always talking
Face Time.
But my daughter, Frankie,
who you just met,
she is constantly
taking screenshots
of me -- of, like, my face.
Because when you're doing
Face Time,
it's not like you're on,
like, a fancy Zoom
and you have a ring light,
and you, like, primp yourself.
You're, like, getting ready
for bed or eating or whatever.
-Yeah, it's family time, yeah.
-It's family time.
And she -- every single time
I see that flash
on the screen, it's just like,
"Jesus, really?"
And so this past year,
they made a calendar
of all of those photos.
They collected them
and made a calendar.
-Of unflattering photos of you.
-Yes.
-You brought a few here.
I just want to show them on
national TV, if you don't mind.
-Yeah, that'd be great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That'd be great.
-This here is some of the
screenshots right here.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Nice, nice.
-What a great family.
-Yeah, it's nice.
-What a lovely family.
-You know --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel like everyone
looks great when
they're blowing their nose.
-[ Laughs ] Everyone does.
-Yeah.
-You mentioned that you're here
filming season two
of "Severance."
Congratulations.
Season one was such a huge hit.
I loved it.
You've been nominated
for almost every award there is.
Congratulations.
Golden Globes, everything.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Emmys -- What can you tell us
about season two?
-You know,
that's the funny thing
is when we're making season one,
we were like,
"This is so weird,
like, is anyone gonna like this
or is everyone just gonna
think this is stupid?"
Like, we couldn't tell.
We loved it and everything,
but you never know.
And it just seemed so strange
that we didn't know.
And now, like,
we have to -- like, all this --
We have secret scripts and have
to use, like, code words
when we're on e-mail and, like,
it's so secret.
It's crazy.
And it's just feels ridiculous.
But it's also great,
because people want to know,
you know.
-Could we set up
the first season of "Severance"
or just what "Severance" is
if you haven't seen the show?
-Yeah, sure, it's a show
that takes place in a world
where there's a technology where
you can split your life in half.
So when you go to work,
you don't know who you are
in the outside world.
And then when you're at home,
you have no idea
who you are at work
or what your job is
or what you do there.
So it's essentially two
separate lives you're leading.
-Yeah, that's a great way
to set it up and then watch it,
and it just gets crazier
and crazier.
It's fantastic.
-Oh, thanks, man.
-I'm just so excited
that you're here
and that you're here
during a very important time.
It's Perm Week
on "The Tonight Show."
And it's a --
-You know, Chris
has a wonderful head of hair,
and you made it even better.
-Right, yeah.
-Like, incredible.
-His hair in general was,
like, unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-I wouldn't even touch it.
I would frame his hair.
-Yeah.
-And then he did it, and now
it even looks even better.
-Oh, it's beautiful.
-It's beautiful.
Have you ever done a perm,
or thought about it?
-Oh, I really -- I mean,
in the '80s, it seemed like
men were getting -- like, guys
that hosted, like,
afternoon talk shows had perms.
-Everybody, yeah, of course,
yeah, I remember.
-Gary Collins would have a perm.
-He did have one, yeah.
-Adam Curry, I think, right?
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, sure,
Adam Curry, yeah.
-Yeah.
I found a old headshot of you,
not permed, just kind of cool,
I would say.
-This is my first headshot,
I believe.
-This feels '90s, right?
-It's '90s.
It's like -- Oh, my God.
You know, listen...
-Who do you --
Wow, you look good.
-It's like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't clap.
You can't clap.
My hair is like a cross
between, like, Eddie Vedder
and Natalie Merchant.
-[ Laughs ]
I like your pose.
How did you --
How does one even --
Look at -- no, look at --
-Oh, my God. It's so terrible.
It's so --
-That looks difficult.
-I mean, that is, like,
profoundly bad.
Like, that's really tough.
-I love it.
I just didn't want you
to feel left out...
-Yeah, I'm sure.
-...so I --
-Oh, yeah.
-Would you?
-Please!
-Can I, please?
-Yeah, please, just...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I love it.
-It feels good.
-It feels right.
-Oh, it's so...
-It feels -- This feels right.
-I feel like my life
coming together.
-Yeah, this is it.
See, you're getting
what Chris was feeling earlier.
-Yes.
-And you're getting
a little taste of it now.
-That's right.
-This is --
Can we talk about "Party Down"?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Please.
This has been -- I missed this.
This has been --
-Yeah.
We're just gonna leave the wigs.
-Yeah, I'm not taking these off.
-13 years...
-13 years since we got canceled
in 2010.
-But what would you --
what was it?
It was just streaming
that made it popular again?
-I guess so.
Because when we finished,
when we were canceled, we were
canceled for, like,
pretty good reason, I guess.
Because our our ratings
were literally 0.0.
-No one was watching.
-No.
-No one watching your show?
So you end up getting canceled.
-That's what happens
when no one watches your show.
-But little by little over
the years, people got into it.
And now I get asked about it,
just, like, out on the street
or whatever.
-Well, it's a cult favorite.
-We get asked about it just
as much as anything else.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's great.
-But everyone came back for it.
-Yeah, yeah.
Lizzy Caplan, because of
scheduling, couldn't do it.
But everyone else --
Jane Lynch, Ken Marino,
Megan Mullally, Ryan Hansen,
Martin Starr, everybody.
-But then who --
and Jennifer Garner --
-Jennifer Garner joined
the show.
-I love Jennifer Garner.
-Yeah.
-Come on.
-She's amazing.
-I can't get enough
Jennifer Garner.
I love her.
-She's the best.
-Do we set this up at all?
How do we set up --
-Yeah, this is, I believe Roman,
Martin Starr's character,
and I talking
in the first episode.
-There you go.
-I don't have
a perm in this clip.
-Don't let everyone down.
-Sorry.
-Guys, no booing when you watch
this clip.
Enjoy it, it's a comedy.
Oh, we should mention
that it's a catering company.
-Yeah, "Party Down" is about
a catering company.
-Thank you.
-A non-permed catering company.
That's all you need to know.
-Why would -- yeah.
It is --
I'm so happy it's back.
I want to show everybody a clip.
Here's Adam Scott in
the new season of "Party Down."
Take a look.
-I accept the possibility
that I probably won't be
appreciated in my lifetime.
You know, if I get discovered
as they're reviewing my papers
after I die,
well, I'll be fine with that.
-So you still doing
mostly hard sci-fi?
-Yeah. You remember
the magnum opus
that I started
on a roll of toilet paper?
Well, that was
just the beginning,
and I'm just kind of
tweaking one little thing,
but then it's ready to sell.
And I still have my blog,
which is now a vlog
because of my carpal tunnel
incident.
-You know what?
I should probably go on out
to the dinner.
-Yeah, see you in 12 years.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's so good, man.
-Thanks, man.
-It made me laugh.
And I've seen
the great reviews, as well.
-Thanks, dude.
-It's getting great reviews.
-Thank you.
-Adam Scott, everybody.
"Party Down" premieres
its third season next Friday
on Starz.
Frankie, keep it up.
That's a good job.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show",
everybody.
Good job, Frankie.
[ Cheers and applause ]